the Dave Matthews Band with music like
the song satellite is among the world's
most successful groups in popular music
the first new album in six years come
tomorrow was released last June it was a
record-setting seventh in a row to debut
at number one but for all of its fame
the Dave Matthews Band hasn't forgotten
the city of Charlottesville Virginia
where it all began we met up with Dave
Matthews there recently to see how the
band is giving back to the city tell me
about the joy of playing music explain
the joy to me where is it something that
when it's perfect
it's like
[Music]
it's like being lifted out of your body
it's like you're not there anymore and
[Music]
no matter how loud the crowd cheers
something about playing in
Charlottesville Virginia keeps Dave
Matthews grounded what's it like coming
to play here it's always harder to play
at home it's a weird feeling always a
homecoming it's always joyful but you
always want to do better I wrote a lot
of my songs in that pink warehouse is it
pink does it look that though Matthews
now lives out west he says his roots
remain here where his eponymous band
began its record ascent to the top of
the Billboard charts in the early 1990s
I couldn't have begged to have a greater
experience playing this band in my life
I want some other experiences but I but
I'd hope feel like I'm entitled to them
because Jesus how can this happen to one
first
[Applause]
[Music]
blessed with fame but also generosity
the Dave Matthews Band has made a habit
of sharing its good fortune you've given
away like more than forty million dollar
like this is so here's Crescent hauls
the band recently committed five million
dollars to reimagine public housing in
Charlottesville beginning with a
complete renovation of this residential
apartment building downtown things are
falling apart elevators don't work and
it's amazing that you can be in the
middle of everything and still be this
neglected you talked about feeling roots
in Charlottesville you bounced around a
lot before that my father and my mother
or south-african my dad was a physicist
and he did research at UVA he passed
away when I was a kid and then we went
back to South Africa for the supportive
family that was there matthews went to
high school there while the
segregationist apartheid was still in
place and then when I finished high
school I got my call-up papers to join
the military there and I thought that's
not something I'm desperate to do and so
I moved back to the States
but when I came back to America I
suddenly was just it was everywhere I
looked I knew there was racism and it
was sort of amazing but it's hit me in
the face all the time
Charlotte's film itself was hit in the
face in August of 2017 with the white
supremacist how did that make you feel
as somebody who has who put down roots
in your hand Charlottesville I don't
know if it's in her knee but I was in
South Africa and I was with family there
and excuse me
and my friend Brian phoned me and said I
think I've just witnessed a murder I
think I've just witnessed a hate crime
it's very hard when you look at what
happened in this town the destruction of
a beautiful possibility and it just
broke it broke my heart to see it happen
but do you think that maybe we can make
some beautiful progress having that
progress for Matthews started with a
concert for Charlottesville in 2017
Charlottesville is a place full of hope
which featured performances from Justin
Timberlake Pharrell and Ariana Grande
and then the cherry on top of all
Cherry's Stevie Wonder's showed up it
was the most amazing concert and we said
what are we gonna do and well let's do
something real for the band that meant
expanding opportunity in addition to
repairing this apartment building they
plan to replace every public housing
unit in the city of Charlottesville all
376 of them we are hoping that it's
gonna jazz it is a transformative effort
residents joy Johnson and Audrey Oliver
have been pushing for for nearly 20
years it would take all of this area
they showed us the first soon-to-be
sight of new public housing in a
generation so is this a turning point I
would say yes yes I think this is this
is the turning point but just to have
someone come in and say what can we do
to help the inequities and the lack of
access that some people experience in
this town like in every town seems like
something that should be remedied and we
are fortunate enough to be able to at
least push it in the right direction so
when the buildings are built here and
people are living here and it's the
grand opening day
what's that party gonna look like
yeah will you need musical accompaniment
oh yes oh yes so I booked you a gig
oh good of course getting a date won't
be easy
loyal fans have kept the Dave Matthews
Band on the road pretty much since their
first gig in Charlottesville nearly
three decades ago are you gonna be
touring until they take your boots off
I don't know I have no idea I dream
about going and living in a hut in Kenya
with and growing my facial hair but I
feel very grateful for being able to
make a noise with people that want to
make a noise because it's a beautiful
opportunity thank you very very much
[Music]
he is such a great guy oh my god think
of what he's gonna do yeah he feels that
in his bones you could see it an Audrey
Oliver and joy Johnson aren't bad either
and a shout out to Joe long reproduce
didn't Brian Cunningham and Lauren honey
Meyer and of course our own resident
Dave Matthews aficionado Adam Verdugo
I'm right up there with that let me say
I knew there was a reason I'm a fan I
listened them throughout college and I
love stories like this yeah well this
gives us all reason to revisit this
story as they begin this project that's
exactly right the best of what's around
that means and you can hear more of
John's conversation with Dave Matthews
on today's CBS this morning podcast is
available on all major podcast platforms
you're watching CBS this morning we will
be right back